استمر مع رد العرضه السعوديه الذي اطلقته
وزاره الثقافه في ساحه الصفات في الرياض
باستقبال الزوار هذا المعرض واحتفت من
خلاله الوزاره بواحد من عناصر التراثق
الثقافي والسعودي وابرزت قيمته الثقافيه
ومدى ارتباطه بالهويه الوطنيه غاد الفهد
يستمر معرض العرضه السعوديه الذي اطلقته
وزاره الثقافه في ساحه الصفات في الرياض
باستقبال الزوار هذا المعرض احتفت من
خلاله الوزاره بواحد من عناصر التراث
الثقافي السعودي
وابرزت قيمته الثقافيه وما ترتيباته
بالهويه الوطنيه اثناء
[موسيقى]
للمملكه
الرسميه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه وهي
العرضه الذي تتمثل فيها نوعيه الشجاعه
والنخوه
والرجوله ومدلولها الجميل الذي يدل على
الفزعه
والحميه هذا يعني شيء نعتز فيه جميعا يعني
تعتز فيه المملكه العربيه السعوديه سواء
شمالها اربعه وهذا شيء جميل جدا وهي
العرضه همم تمارس في جميع انحاء المملكه
العربيه السعوديه العامه
السعوديه الى التعريف بها بوصفها فنان
سعوديا اصيلا وتصحيح المفاهيم المرتبطه
بها اضافه للاحتفاء بها باعتبارها تراثا
ثقافيا عالميا غير مادي مسجلا لدى
اليونسكو منذ عام 2015
غدا الفهد العربيه الرياض